in regarding to dubs there's been a lot
of trade rumors I know my name has came
up I know everyone name has come up
except for Steph Curry to be honest I
have not thought about it one bit I hear
all the same things that all you guys
hear I know we've been linked to a
pascal seaka you know everybody saying
oh the Warriors got to make a trade
they're going to make a trade I mean if
you're 18 and
22 how can you question anything someone
does so we've never really been a active
team at the trade deadline like over the
course of 12 Years that's what eight and
N guys it's not a lot however we also do
have a new gym and Mike has been
incredible by the way you know he could
work differently than Bob he could be
more aggressive at the trade deadline
than Bob were I don't know I don't
really have a feel for it do I think
I'll be traded I hope not